Should all patients be taking vitamin D if not recommended through the testing if so how much and what brand yes, probably not everybody needs to be taking vitamin D through the summer if you get outside a lot.
The brand there's multiple really good brands of vitamin D. I like it's you should be using vitamin D three that's about all you can find now anyhow. I like a vitamin D that also has the other fats all the vitamins in it.
Because I do think there's a city just to connect with the fats all you play supplements.
So we use that ADK avail.
That's the product for designs for health now I think we have a private label.
That's I think one of the better products of the market.
Partly because it has the full has the delta total treat on the e unit where some of the full spectrum vitamin D's mean full spectrum meeting that they're carry the other fats all of the vitamins, some of them are only carry the health to control.
And you really want the total tree and also the vitamin D.
Are there any other supplements might have a mineral center that you would recommend everyone to take well if you're doing the greens product so if you're taking the greens first.
There is a necessary you need to be taking these other things because that is multiple in itself so no.
Some people have deficiencies in minerals for different reasons so like for me in the summertime i'm out gardening that's what I love to do.
So my wife and I are really big gardeners I wish I could have you all over the house to see all areas beds and all our gardens.
That's just I just we just love to do that so we're outside sweating a lot so we take minerals every day.
Besides the greens first so that's something we take I do not take the vitamin D in the summer unless I feel like I've come it down with some things feeling off that I'll take some vitamin D.
But I always take minerals in the summer just because of that if you're doing it sawdust and you know a couple times a week it might be good to have minerals as well because you're sweating.
The more you're sweating you're sweating out toxins that's a benefit of the sauna that's a benefit of going outside of the summertime and really sweating.
But you are those heat minerals too so you just want to make sure you that dehydrated just by drinking water we have well water that has minerals in it but still we take minerals because I could feel.
I could just tell my legs get kind of crampion stuff for no reason probably deficiencies in minerals.